today's episode is brought to you by
liquid death i want to let you know we
got uh new be good to yourself colorways
merch available now
hoodies crew necks and tees
also available is the i'm upstairs
collection baby let them know where you
are
what are you i'm upstairs
and the new get that header bait and
tackle collection they got these hats
right there then brims baby
catch that fish in comfort now check out
that and more at theovonstore.com
that's theovonstore.com
um i want to let you know though i got
some new tour dates that you can check
out
and i'm grateful for them uh february
2nd i'll be in jacksonville florida
the third
st petersburg
uh the fifth i'll be in orlando the 24th
i'll be in lafayette indiana the 25th
rockford
illinois home of the rockford peaches
and that's america's team right there
female ball
february 26 chicago illinois uh
may 6th in tulsa may 7th in los angeles
today's guests are a real tandem
a real duet if you will
they are one of a kind men in their own
right
and they have joined forces
from their new podcast hawk vs wolf they
are the greatest skateboarder of all
time mr tony hawk and one of the most
multifaceted men of all time mr jason
ellis
grateful to have them here today
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Applause]
you got to do some of those mexican
shows man the mexican shows like uh
what's that show with those four people
colin
out in the valley somewhere it's like
two mexican kids and a um
chinese person you don't talk about it
in a vietnamese person they speak
english though right yeah yeah yeah
everybody speaks english it's good
oh it's like something i literally did a
mexican game show there you go it was
pretty insane oh there you go that's
they're not they're speaking spanish in
that right but the whole country's again
so you got to jump over world wide but
it was like it was like this giant it's
like a brother's thing that you had to
throw these balls down they bounced and
they were hitting the audience and stuff
it was crazy man i want to do that why
don't they do that here i want to throw
giant balls of people it's because of
the different legislation i think you
know like certain countries you can uh
i mean the rules are definitely
different on who can die skateparks when
i was a kid they just built giant boat
ramps and put them in a [ __ ] park in
here the only person that had giant vote
ramp is some pro dude that's got all the
insurance and [ __ ] rich guys
sorry i don't mean to point at you dude
and you might not have any money anymore
i don't know but
there was a time i might have to sell my
ramp for scraps
and wouldn't it be crazy we walk up on
him in winter and he's like making
firewood out of his last ramp you know
to stay warm that'd be a really sad day
no that thing's here to stay oh good i'm
glad man um
yeah thank you guys for coming in man i
appreciate it dude it's good to see you
again
you know and thank you for you know
whenever i was just uh really kind of
catching a break in comedy you brought
me onto your serious so a couple times
oh really that was what that because i
didn't realize you hadn't already i
didn't think i had a i've i heard you on
opie and anthony i i told you and was
like holy [ __ ] this guy's the funniest
guy i've ever heard on radio that's what
how long ago it was
and i was like get him on my show
and then sure enough he just you know
i'm like he didn't know it yet but he's
like an amazing i was like you could
[ __ ] take over any are you saying you
gave him his big break no not at all he
i'm saying he was already you're kind of
saying that he helped him he helped
hammer the crack i think everybody
already knew though i don't think i was
let me show you [ __ ] theo vaughn
everybody everyone like did you on the o
a show it wasn't it wasn't you weren't
well it was just opie at that point and
you're but you're sorry your show had a
big all your no you definitely given me
like a
a nod of confidence it was like you and
simon rex kind of did it at the same
time and that was i think really helpful
so [ __ ] it so thanks man i appreciate it
i never really kind of thanked you for
that wow uh amazing
what's going on so you guys are up to
this [ __ ] now huh
sorry we started we started at siriusxm
yeah
before my show that's how i got it
oh okay he got me on okay yeah and then
we were doing that for a while and then
he went off to
somewhat greener pastures and started
being the voice of the channel we were
on for the most part and then i kept
doing the podcast and then
i was just kind of getting buried in
there
what do you think you were missing like
when he wasn't there was there something
that you felt like you were missing
um
yeah definitely a a a edgier comedy i
would say yes which wasn't good at the
time it was
it was pretty raw and we i had a lot of
i had a lot of kids listening because it
was oh yeah it was different very much
still
skating and we were doing video games
and they wanted to hear about that and
play music and then this guy would bring
yeah very unfiltered but it was
hilarious um but then um
but then like i said we just just kind
of fizzled out
and then he started podcasting and and i
hit him up and i said maybe we should
try something and so we started trying
it and it it kind of clicked and it's
been fun yeah it feels fun it feels fun
to watch you guys i try to think when i
when i watch i feel like um
yeah i feel like you guys have a comfort
level with each other there's a real
earnestness that comes out of you a lot
that i think creates this makes you kind
of be the same way
i don't know i haven't watched a ton but
from what i've seen it's uh it seems
like
like a new little not like a marriage
but like a new little like okay no it's
good it's spring time at the house yeah
you gave me a key to the ramp the other
day and i
i thought it was
just as good as an engagement ring to me
what's happening for sure to escape ramp
to my ramp
okay so yeah is it like you know you
said only rich guys have their own ramps
yeah yeah yeah it's a total rich guy and
it also has a lock out front of it that
definitely it's in a warehouse oh it is
although someone broke in the other
night stole some camera gear oh i
thought they just skated no skating just
i know i was kind of hoping that too
just waiting hey what are you doing
well you gave l's a key you didn't give
me one
somebody broke my phone somebody broke
in here too actually
soul cameras yeah all right oh yeah it
must be that time of year maybe the
holidays people are looking
you know to give cameras out or
something well they they were going
around the building trying to get into
different doors and finally got into
the door that just happened to be
by a camera that was set up oh yeah
that's a game show for criminals i feel
like they just walk into a building and
it's like
yeah if he had gotten the other door
open he would have had
uh
a piece of the of the loop
oh
the loop ramp is all set up over there
that would have been hard that would be
hard to steal on a win i was going to
say and what would you do like if theo
stole the loop
what would you do i've gotten hurt
nothing the first
i'd probably take it to canada or
australia where people would freaking
mount somebody you could sell it for big
money over there i think but
how do you i mean how do you get it
there yeah shipping i don't know canada
maybe you could drive it through in a
truck yeah but australia no got hawks
loot can you imagine trying to
get through trying to get just get rid
of it yeah
yeah who watch what i'm saying
you want a loop yeah like hey kid you
want to die i got the device
like just just set this thing up and go
down that road and you'll be dead in a
minute like no problem yeah bro this
path has fentanyl in it yeah
the suicide loop the loop just takes
people out
yeah i mean it's i i did it and it was
one of the most
painful
terrifying experiences of my skateboard
career really it was hard work for sure
some people get it a little easier but i
was already on my way out doing radio
and not skateboarding all the time and
he was like we're setting up the loop
and i was like well [ __ ] if you're
calling me that's
it's a it's a prestige you know to do
the loop i think you've done like 10
people had done it
and i was like well this is an
opportunity for me to and all americans
all white like whites all women oh who
was it who all had done it
you want the demographics everything
everything oh
yeah yeah i'm not judging i don't know
you haven't seen this would i be
frustrated i've never been asked that
question am i the first gay guy i'm the
only i believe so yeah oh yeah there you
go
what lizzie armando was the first female
right oh wow okay
and then uh
felipe nunez did it with uh no legs he
he has no legs
a little bit though don't you think
no it was so hard for us to get the
speed for him we had to build an
extension on the starting ramp for him
look at it is that it the actual yeah
well it's pretty gnarly dude like when
you get on this charlie this is uh um
tom sharra got broke off here it's like
being in the dryer for a really couple
seconds yeah yeah
but you can't lose
where you are if you do that you're dead
what do you look at when you go into the
line oh look at the line he's got a line
in the middle of it and you follow the
line because especially if you're if
you've got skateboarding in your in your
background when you get to the upside
down part you want to look back because
that's what you usually do you're going
you're usually turning around oh yeah so
you got to not look back and keep
looking at this line and it just doesn't
seem
right
so you
you want to do that little lean and then
that makes you do this twisty thing and
you eat [ __ ] well i'm just trying to say
because i never now it's a lot more
diverse when i was young it was like
white dudes who had been
who were about to fight their stepfather
were the ones who were skateboarding
yeah i hated those guys
yeah yeah i got that's how that's how i
became me talking about jason i mean
okay maybe i grew up with those guys i
had to like you know i got approval
after many years of hard work and you
know humiliation and
and you know they just
they destroy you and call you a pile of
[ __ ] and throw your board in the trash
one time i made checkers i told this
story but i made checkers inside
checkers with the grip tape on the board
so it took like oh a couple days oh yeah
because i've got a lot of school doing
that it had to be perfect and i'm not
very like good with like art and [ __ ] my
i got big dumb hands so it took forever
so i got checkers and checkers on this
board and i show up like [ __ ]
christian or soy boy with checkers and
checkers i'm like get the i'm the
[ __ ]
sickest dude yeah out here and i get on
the ramp and this dude that's now my
friend zach reynolds
he goes what the [ __ ] is that [ __ ]
and just grabs it off me and throws it
in the trash can oh
and
but
i just grabbed it out of the trash can
and kept skating because that's how it
goes it happened all the time yeah and
now they're nice to me
well it only took like page
yeah 30 years
now it's like man how's it looking good
in the states jason send us a t-shirt
i'm like i'm not sending you [ __ ]
jason get stuffed
we had uh
i'm trying to think if we had a lot of
skateboarding aria we had one dude
jumped off the shonies one time on a
board
and uh
what's a shoney it's a shony's it's like
a place where you get food it's like a
denny's yeah it's like a denny's but
it's off the roof
roof yeah but he hit a buick all the
saber and can you pull up a little saber
daddy wait while it was moving no no no
still a savior oh yeah wait he didn't
see not ate it properly i think he
didn't plan ahead really yeah i think
some people think when you're going off
a roof you're going to be able to jump
but i think the angle you oh i see he
just went straight down eliminates that
he hit a maroon one too
that's a good look
yeah not a bag i mean it was a cool but
anyway yeah he like shattered his neck
or whatever which i didn't think you
could shatter like your neck's already
kind of in like different pieces i feel
like so it's like to sh you know but
they said he shattered his neck but he
wore a neck brace forever after that
it's an interesting theory on your neck
uncharterable
they don't shatter because there's
pieces in there
that's an interesting theory is all i'm
saying they're already perforated i mean
yeah i mean we're not doctors on this
side of the table but what the [ __ ]
there
you can shatter you can shatter pretty
much anything
it doesn't seem like i speak from
experience
shattering seems like it like a hard
word to use for the neck but
i don't know what's a what's what is
something that most people what's the
first thing most people break down
skateboarding
uh ankles wrists
yeah yeah whipping off put your hands oh
it's so scary wheeled things have always
super super scared me i don't like uh i
don't even like being in a car if
if it's in neutral
and it's off like i don't do well on
anything that has like loose just like
has the ability to be loose under it you
know your commitment is just gonna take
off i think i just don't trust the
anything gravity just me in between me
and the earth i probably don't even
trust gravity i'm very non-committal
um what about this right here this is a
fellow sent something in is this decent
what's up theo uh jason and tony uh it's
louie here from australia razor blades
baby what um
if you say rise
rise up lights real fast
rise up lights it sounds like razor
blades in australia okay rise up lights
razor blades no rise up lights
yeah but i'm saying this the australian
thing i see
yeah you do razor blades then i'll do go
rise up lights razor blades rise up
lights razor blades
razor blades rise of light let's just
keep doing that and then that's a
podcast
razor blades razor blades rise up light
sigma yeah
okay
anyway so obviously
theo uh jason and tony uh it's louie
here from australia razor blades baby um
just want to know what you boys are tony
and jason what's the the gnarliest
injury you guys have seen
in skateboarding uh whether it be
professional or just down at the skate
park on the ramp um anyway cheers fellas
gang gang baby
cheers baby that guy's from another
country
that happens sometimes
well
i guess now with all the new rules seen
have people died
uh well there's beyond people have died
yes not and i'm not barren i have not
been witness to that
no
thankfully um
but i i well the worst that i the worst
i had was broken pelvis
and i fractured my skull and broke my
thumb all at the same time so you're
gonna do it do it big right [ __ ] you're
half a mummy at that point but i was but
i wasn't i was knocked out so it wasn't
like i was witnessing all this it makes
it easier right what's that yeah a
little bit but i i want to say like the
worst the worst thing you say i saw a
dude break his arm here
and then his arm was just dangling and
like
dangling behind him that's pretty cool
like it was just flopping around that
was pretty heavy i smashed my i
fractured my wrist i broke my wrist and
i popped my elbow out of the back of my
arm
like compound fracture
when i was 16 and i was gonna i was
about to get on a plane to go back to
melbourne and i was like we'll just
skate to skate park near the airport and
then
i fell and that thing came out
that was
it was good that i was young because i
just went into shock and then they gave
they give you a whistle in australia you
suck on a whistle for what if you need
help nah it's got heroin in it
yeah
what
yeah well whatever it's got whatever
morphine or whatever you know oh boy huh
it's got the
he's like suck on the whistle and then
you realize when you suck on it that
it's it's got heroin in it and then you
suck that [ __ ] yeah
yeah
and then they take the whistle off
you're like no give me the whistle back
yeah yeah i'd be fine crossing guard in
a half hour
i'd [ __ ]
just be bringing a [ __ ] lord across
the street son whistles are good yeah
that's insane i had that dope whistle
over there man yeah i've never heard of
that yeah
that's the thing i think it seems like
you guys dynamic is that you're gonna
somehow
you would seem like you would know so
much but you're gonna learn a lot from
them oh yeah i just don't know if it's
good or not no i gotta filter which
parts yeah yeah it's always it's always
enlightening and it's always
entertaining yeah
um yeah and we
we try to keep it
family-ish friendly yeah yeah i got a
jason ella show to get real yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah so yeah there's been a couple
times where his stories went crossed
over once again
okay yeah maybe you would understand
like every now and then at a certain
place where it might not be might not be
super appropriate to
go deep into your own head because
you're pretty gross you know yeah i mean
i've been involved in some stuff that's
probably not
you know stuff you would talk about with
someone's mom or something if you just
met them sure
right so i feel like
we all have yeah yeah yeah yeah so
that's more his brand oh yeah yeah he
definitely my penis is involved in a lot
yeah
so i keep that out of the hawk versus
wolf yeah
yeah it almost seems like your opinion
is like you're its parole officer that's
what it sounds like a lot of times now i
do argue with it a lot yeah
sometimes it feels like it's missed a
court date or two it kind of
he's in trouble he's in trouble right
now actually
what um jason i know that you love uh
mma and uh
and skateboarding i know that that's
part of your uh your past and fighting
is something you just love to do you
know uh competition is there uh was
there ever a a skateboarder or somebody
like a ramp man or something that you uh
that you would
wouldn't want to tangle with or that was
like somebody who was like a real badass
that was like what's this dude doing
skating this guy should be fighting i
never wanted to fight i don't like
fighting i don't like the the
the argument or
where people are heated i'm not into
that at all i've never been into that
like if i have to defend myself because
i've been in bad situations so
instinctually i if you're going to
corner me then i'm going to go because i
know what the other
the other side of that is like if you
don't defend yourself you just get [ __ ]
kicked and i'm not going to let that
happen ever again yeah so there's that
but i don't like
the fight fight thing and in
skateboarding people are either really
short or maybe tall and skinny
but it's not a good it doesn't help to
be kind of bulky um so it's kind of like
it's kind of like comedy all right you
know with the holidays i find sometimes
i get distracted discouraged
and i'll you know some people even feel
depressed during the holidays and
you know because there's so much cheer
in the air and they maybe feel well i'm
not having any cheer
well that can be uh that can be adjusted
you know and something that can help
adjust it is um is better help
better help
b e t t e r h e l
you can start communicating with a real
therapist in under 48 hours
so in less than 48 hours you can be
getting some help
you know and it's real help these are
licensed
uh
you know
these are real this is real help
you get timely and thoughtful responses
you can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions
uh you can start to put a plan
into feeling better and
and feeling better is a possibility i
want to let you know that
visit betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o that's better h-e-l-p
dot com
theo
i've gotten on better help
and uh
you know i damn
had to pull over on the side of the road
and face time with a woman
a therapist a woman and and it was good
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and tpw listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
theo
man there's nothing that that really
gets my gizzard more
that really just yurks my damn uh
my yank
more than um if if a free trial started
on something you know you sign up for a
meat subscription or a
you know a turkey
you know a non-beef endeavor monthly or
something
and they keep sending it though and they
you know you cancel it but it keeps you
know it's just
there's no way to chart all that stuff
these days to know what subscriptions
are yours you're getting a bag of
barrettes in the mail and you're
bald-headed
it's gotta stop well truebill
is the new app that helps you identify
and stop paying
for subscriptions that you don't need or
want or even that you forgot about it
just sort of remind you hey do you still
you still want this caviar you know
you're homeless do you still want the
the cavi
on average
people save up to 720 a year with true
bill yep
true bill concierge is there when you
need them to cancel unwanted
subscriptions so you don't have to
that's nice you don't have to law you
forgot the past where you don't even
remember the website
just like yeah
they can help
truebill has over 2 million users and
helped save them from over and help save
them over 100 million dollars that's a
lot of money
like matthew b says in a matter of
seconds i saved 660 dollars for the year
on my directv bill
saved 120 for the year on my sirius xm
and saved it 840 a year on car insurance
don't fall for subscription scams
sometimes they trick you
you order a omelet and then they egg in
you for a decade
don't fall for those scams start
canceling today at truebill.com
t-h-e-o
go right now
truebill.com
theo it could save you thousands a year
bulky you don't see a lot of bulky
comics the only real one is joe rogan
but he's a bit short yeah that's a good
point he's a bit short because in
skateboarding he you can be a bit bulky
and be his height if you're like six
foot and bulky skateboards barely hold
me oh like they the tail flexes out if i
get a little too thick
i can't go hard you can't really get
that fluid style either
if you were if you were bigger and
bulkier you know it would just it would
feel more
forced there was one other guy tom boyle
oh what happened to him he passed away
recently actually oh everybody's dying i
know but uh he was an amazing
skateboarder and he was jack he was
he was pretty thick dude yeah i guess
have there ever had jamie foy is like
breaking all the rules who's that jamie
foy's street skater oh who's this he's
bigger and he's he's he's one of the
best like jamie you ask kids you bring
him up brother f-o-i-e
f-o-y-o
um
he's amazing like that and you you see
him just like that's not a typical
skater
who's that greyhound out there who's
that thick daddy that's out there
they got any big dogs that get out on
the board
there was a guy that tried to drop in my
ramp yeah
you want to see something heavy yeah
literally heavy yeah put oh here's jamie
foy jimmy james insane he's he's
seriously like he's one of the best
skaters right now
this guy yeah he's not jacked no nice
jack just bigger like he's
he's a bigger dude there we go
oh yeah he's a little thick huh
look at that
oh yeah where you going
like
he's slanging breasts skateboarding for
i know for a fact if you're bigger it's
the fall that's hot yeah
yeah
i'd be good at skateboarding if i wasn't
such a [ __ ] dude i'd be good at it i
bet
so there's not hand feet coordination
i think i would have really if i could
have really focused on it it seems like
it takes a lot of real focus in a
strange way
yeah i don't know what's the best
element to be a skateboarder like what
is the thing
i never given up really because you got
to do it over and over again sometimes
it seems impossible but if you go enough
all of a sudden you can but there's so
many different elements too that that
you could be good at so you can kind of
focus in on well i'm really good at
doing these types of flip tricks yeah
and and getting them into grinds and
stuff and that can just be your whole
brand
yeah and then other people are like they
just fly they fly out of our ramps
and they're just that's true thing and
everyone loves to see them fly and
that's good enough right um some people
have a little bit of all of it but then
some are like high like you know if you
look at nigel houston just precision
technical
like beyond any olympian wow
he looks like a video game yeah he yeah
yeah
it's like the board when it's not
he's still with him oh wow yeah
sometimes you see people like that that
start to change the way that things are
done like patrick mahomes kind of
changes the quarterback position you're
like oh i didn't think that this could
even be played differently yeah and then
it seems like he just plays the game
differently or at a speed that looks
totally new for some reason whether it's
faster or slower than what's been done
what about that thick dog who is the big
guy
he's known as big boy yeah literally
and he used to be a skater this is a
good sleep skating in orange county
uh-huh and uh he was making waves
because he does a lot of weight lifting
stuff he's he's big dude oh he's like
yeah yeah yeah crazy like five people he
looks like five people but he started to
he started to reach like if he had a big
[Laughter]
in a pajama suit
he had a clip that went viral doing a
kick flip or something or an ollie and
everyone was just like dude i was like
you know and you could tell that he had
already had the skate skills but he's
gotten big yeah and then he re so then
he started hit me up like man i want to
drop in on your ramp and i was like
yeah you might want to work your way up
to it yeah because everything that i saw
him riding was maybe four to five feet
my gram's 14 feet but you let him in yep
yeah it accommodates on his ass yeah and
uh he came in he came in hot
he was not going to take the time to
figure it out he just wanted to go yeah
boy when you thick i think you life's
short you find that you got to go quick
interesting just look up tony hawk big
boy you got him let's see him oh damn
huh
yeah dude somebody is that tattoo or did
somebody graffiti on him that dude
he had a nap and somebody graffitied him
yeah what if somebody just tagged him up
yeah there you go in arizona for an hour
so watch him he would not
hesitate or take direction he just said
i'm going i'm committing
what oh what
that was awesome that was a tease that's
how they do it wow they did a great job
youtube man
oh i feel taking advantage i almost feel
like all right
we fell for it so this is this is his
warm-up that ramp's about six feet not a
good idea and i kept telling him like
you got it you got to bend your knees
more because you're straightening his
straightening his legs too much yeah he
looks like the singer on a cruise line
kind of i don't know yeah he looks like
somebody was waiting bar on a cruise and
so when he got to the top of the vert
ramp
i said all right you just got to bend
your knees you know connect to the wall
first he's like all right so just commit
i said that's not what i said oh yeah
yeah at all
oh yes dude oh damn boy yeah he's not
going hard oh yeah but it's fun to watch
though
that's ryan sheckler helping him out
really yeah here we go you had everybody
there
oh
damn is it okay to laugh and you all see
where oh yeah
yeah
wow
i mean that's what it looks like that's
usually when people get knocked out
and so i thought that was it but he made
some crazy sounds that was brave he got
that gingerbread bill he built like that
little gingerbread man
yeah you know he looks like a
gingerbread man they just got out of san
quentin
but he was he was super cool about it
and he still hit me up since then like
yo man i want to come back for it so is
it is that like your it's almost like
that's your vagina like if somebody
drops in on your ramp is it kind of have
that sort of feel to it like is it like
all dudes trying to get in there
it sounds like you're not saying it he's
the only guy
like nobody it would be it would be
i would come down
every time if you were like hey i got
like five guys that are all trying to
come down today
i'll be there in a minute nobody i mean
there are there are a handful of people
that come and that's their directive and
and for whatever reason i'll let them go
but it's more that people want to come
to skate my ramp because they sleep
right the guy that owns liquid death
he came oh yeah and he's talking and i
just met him and he's like yeah we're
talking and he's like we're going out
into the ram i'm like you're going to
escape i didn't know he could skate he
could skate out a mini ramp at liquid
death nail and he can skate wow but
skating a mini ramp and skating his ramp
is two different things two different
animals and we're talking chit-chatting
i'm skating and i guess he's on the deck
and i'm like if you're on the deck you
can skate yeah this you don't get the
deck the top of the ramp yeah yeah so
he's up there hanging out and then i
guess he'd drop in and i didn't i wasn't
watching i figured everybody could drop
in no big deal so i see out of the
corner of my eye right when he drops in
and
if he would have been so [ __ ]
but he him had it yeah so i didn't know
it was scary it was scary i just every
time i see i saw him the other day at
liquid death and i was like dude that
drop in like i can't forget it's like a
trick in itself because he should have
died what if he drowned always think
what if the liquid death got drowned and
it was just like
what in everybody literally
that's how he went out oh he drowned
yeah i thought he meant like joanne
i've thought about it at least probably
five six times i bet
dude cause i think cause that segway
dude went off that mountain member
he was stunned and he bought the segways
and he bought the company and then he
[ __ ] did one right off the mountain
yeah
because you don't know enough about the
vert fam wow you know you got to drop in
different dude i think right
yes but how many dudes are in your dms
be like hey let me get up in that ramp
you know that's what i feel like it
would be old but but it's like i said
it's mostly people that know how to
skate ramps okay it's not it's not just
a big influx of people like i want to
jump in on that thing yeah let me hit
that yeah and and i've seen it go yeah
let me see there's a couple
they would know if they if you go there
like you could talk but then when you go
there and stand on the top of it yeah
you know
you don't just you don't let me you
don't let anybody just no one's gonna
just go go have it you won't go you
heard the slow-mo guys
um
so the youtube show these guys do crazy
stuff in in high definition slow mo like
really high-speed cameras and they came
and they wanted to shoot me doing a
trick which we did and then one of the
hosts was like hey i wanna i wanna try
this and
then that became the thing
he clearly was not ready for it
and took a slam worse than big boy
like his feet missed the board when he
went in you just dove to the bottom oh
there you go
is that is that it
oh these goons would get boiled bro look
at these clowns
so the guy on the right oh
what they're going to do this bro i
think this might be the one where i'm
it's they did they did two segments on
when they came so
are they really wearing those like for a
joke or are they no that's their that's
their vibe okay oh bro
i've had i've cleared stronger things
out of my throat than these dudes
so this is this this video was just my
trick oh
so it's like super high speed i did a
heel flip melon body burial
of course dude um you love that trick
right theo uh of course bro my cousin
had a lobotomy 6
67. but anyway that dude fell
and
he um wow that's cool that dude fell and
broke his wrist oh sorry mate and when
he hit
he farted so bad yeah
no way when we came to check on him
we're like
oh
dude he didn't [ __ ] his pants i i don't
know he might have shitty pants
you could shoot your pants on it he was
so stunned
he was so stunned that his homies shoot
happens you uh oh yeah dude i've [ __ ] i
mean yeah i've actually off way less
than this
oh yes dude come on you can just tell
it's not gonna work
right
like don't do it dude oh god he's oh man
he's just
yeah he knows he's already stalled too
long he knows
and he broke his wrist and he fought it
the whole time he was fighting
could you hear it or not no no when we
walked over to it was like oh
did he [ __ ] his pants that's the last
healthy part of him being like i'm out
of this [ __ ] clown
that's the ghost of his manliness flying
out of his ass bro if you [ __ ] cooked
out like right dude all his heart and
courage is in his fancy right now
yeah
they might have left before he hit
he looked like he was pretty scared
before he went in look at you smiling
dude that's great
well it was it was you know the whole
thing was supposed to be just my trick
and then this became
the highlight of the whole day
i love how the other dude in the lab
coat doesn't even [ __ ] help him bro
you can't dress like a doctor and not do
doctor [ __ ] a little at least cpr your
homie dog
yeah at least suck on his face for a
second [ __ ] bring him back to life
dude
they got to try it again they need to do
a rebuttal or whatever he didn't come
back did anybody ever think you're
daniel tosh ever
no somewhere no
tom green i used to get tom green
when tom green's show was big on mtv
people would think i was tom green oh
that's interesting yeah um
so what else is i thinking about dude uh
who do people think you look like uh i
used to get tom brady when i was a
little bit younger and then
now nobody really just you yeah just me
or just they don't know who i am right
hey what's up this is uh josh from
toronto i'm just wondering uh this is a
question for all of you guys uh whether
you had
any superstitions
that you needed to do before
performing
especially early on when there was low
stakes
sometimes our anxiety makes us want to
be in control and superstitions are a
way of controlling things uh in the
periphery of uncontrollable situations i
don't know if that's true i made that up
on the spot okay um thank you for your
time
again damn dude
what he's getting deep he could be smart
are you superstitious is that what the
question was yeah i used to have
i guess i had little things i did but
like i put on my pads on left side first
yeah i used to be crazy superstitious
and then when i got let go uh from
sirius
i decided that all my uh didn't work
yeah that all my superstition things
obviously didn't [ __ ] work so because
i wouldn't walk on cracks on the street
i used to dodge cracks for like
10 years yeah and then and then i just
decided what i got when i got fired that
i i was going to never matter i was
going to step on cracks i go underneath
[ __ ] i go underneath uh ladders and
[ __ ] everybody can eat a dick i hate it
yeah i think it's funny
when you're younger you do think like
maybe things like that matter like way
in the balance like little things like
i'm racist swallowing different sides of
my mouth for about maybe 15 years you
know like i would swallow like even it
out yeah just to eat it out just to keep
the world even it was almost like a way
of just like trying to keep the world
even so that [ __ ] didn't get too haywire
it was like maybe a control a mechanism
um
you guys ever have any stalkers you guys
are having a good experience with
stalkers
i think both you guys have had at least
one
i don't have my
miner i'm not famous i like like come on
stalk me i would love attention yeah i'm
a [ __ ] egotistical idiot
everybody [ __ ] stalks me i think they
stalk me and then i go hey you want to
get coffee and they're like what the
[ __ ] dude you're pretty pretty intense i
think i'm gonna stalk tony hawk
uh i i
in the 80s
in the 80s there was a girl that paid
the front desk to tell her which room i
was in so that she could get a room next
to mine nice
and then
and then what but uh nothing happened
she did knock on my door one time and
then
like it was sometime through the weekend
she knocked on my door and then she did
come in for a little bit nothing nothing
happened but all of a sudden this
slamming on the door came
and i guess it was her boyfriend oh that
guy that knew the whole
scoop of what she was up to
i'm just i'm just like i didn't even
know that this girl had already done
this i found this out later right and
then the next day
uh i'm getting in the elevator and the
dude i didn't know it was him because i
hadn't seen him and you all got in this
he goes in the elevator and he looks at
me and he's got a cast on no
and why what happened to me and he's
like sorry about slamming on your door
last night broke my wrist oh
idiot like i i was overreacting i'm
sorry i was like and he apologized yeah
well i guess he was drunk i feel sorry
for that guy that was a that was an odd
one yeah i was just sort of okay they
don't i feel like they're well yeah what
you got you got i kind of had that then
yeah because girls are trying to sleep
with me and usually they just can and
it's fine
but one time at ellis mania they had
this fight called the strip fight where
uh every 30 seconds we decide who won
the 30 seconds and
the the person that loses takes an item
of close closing off until they're down
to a g string in pasties so i just go
regardless i go you lost you lost you
lost you lost
right now you're both naked fight
yeah so then they fight and that's kind
of the thing so one of the people you
know dm me that they're they get
fighters you're not allowed to know how
to fight that's the whole point you're
supposed to i'm terrified what is it
like to fight and i go i'll hook you up
in a fight where you get a real fight
but you're not going to get really hurt
okay joe rogan might disagree but it's a
couple of shots yeah and if you look
like you're in trouble we just call it
we don't let you like bleed really cook
out yeah you can't be grilling them out
right so this girl's nice enough she
does the fight awesome fight she looks
great she's got a what i assume is a
boyfriend but it's like uh everyone has
this uh you're allowed to bring a coach
or whatever or or just a plus one so you
got a man over there helping her out a
little later yeah so there's after party
and i got this big room with all this
[ __ ] at the hard rock
and she's hanging out and she's asking
if she can sleep with me
and um who's she asking me and i go i go
well katie
my wife i go she wants to sleep with me
she's like yeah whatever
and i'm and i go what about this guy
who's this guy she gets just my coach oh
and i go oh well then okay no problem
and then i and then she's hanging out
and i look at him and i'm like he's
obviously bummed oh and i go hey man
what's what's going on you're right over
there he's like you know she's just you
know
it's been going out with the with each
other for like some amount of years and
i'm like what we broke up i'm like but
you're i'm like i'm so out of this you
guys need to spend time together go get
him a little gift certificate or
something i can't play that game but
yeah every now and then somebody just
tries to rank check yeah i get them well
i have to feel like star
because some of my friends always get
stalkers and i'm like damn i can't get i
think soccer's is more of a sex thing if
you're good at if you do good sex
then i think you get a stalker you know
you mean somebody you've already had sex
with and it was so good that they just
keep
i feel like that's the only way it would
make sense like if you kinda are okay at
sex i don't think anybody you know
smashing through your window to get back
and hang out with you yeah
i thought stalkers you'd never be yeah
nobody's getting a little more
mentally unstable and it's not but
something has to spark that stalk you
gotta you gotta light that up
a lot of times they think that whatever
whatever art you're doing whatever
whatever content you're creating is
speaking directly to them
all right i mean that seems like the
more scary stalker not
hey i like you and i'm trying to get to
you
i i i guess i had a girl who left her
vax card on my window
and they said she wrote check me for
covet on there charlotte was her name
but i've never had anybody like my
friends get the girls they're jumping
over the fence or yelling and they're
throwing stuff through the windows
they're showing up at their like you're
talking about groupies not stalkers
i i don't know these are the ones
they've had to call the cops
wow
not stalkers yeah so really
but i think they got to be sexually
motivated i don't think anybody's
[ __ ]
smashing through your living room window
to [ __ ] come watch an episode of uh
dexter new blood or something you know
i'm saying like i think you got to have
like a real
you got to have fused them up with some
cop it's an interesting theory i think
because now i feel like any guy that's
like a super fan
kind of wants to have sex with me
it's getting to that point it feels like
a lot of oh some fans would let you
would let you have sex with their males
even who's do you think somebody's super
famous like a guy because i always said
if let's say if i wasn't uh part gay i
would i would like blow david bowie
before he died yeah yeah yeah pre-death
yeah no and i wouldn't say that would
make me gay john would you act out
blowing him even though he's deceased
with that well like ghosts blow him yeah
no
i feel like it's close i feel like
kissing people and sucking dick he's a
gay leader we're killing time here
that's what we're doing man
you know the dude who is standing on the
ramp just like this for a while
that's what we're doing bro
we're just trying not to freaking
[ __ ]
in a minute
um
what else is something fun that i want
to ask you guys here's a beautiful
question right here by some hard young
male
hey boys
greetings from uh vista
had a quick question for jason here you
know i've been listening to you since i
was a little kid the back of my mom's
honda civic ever since the
days of your beef with ello cool j
it was funny but jason i was wondering
you know someone who's grown up around
with a family with a lot of addiction
you know i i uh
i was curious because you're now very
open about your sexuality at this point
and i've always wondered you know do you
think that that that drugs were more of
an opportunity for you to unlock
something that was always inside of you
or do you feel like you know kind of the
extremes of your sexuality have been
part of lusting after a different high
and without drugs do you think that
you'd be the same person that that you
are sober now today or do you think that
was always kind of a part of you
um
and that's a lot right
can i just answer the first one yeah um
i don't think i'm bi because i did drop
do drugs
i think i definitely did
when i did drugs it helped me
uh
do things that i was scared to do
for sure when it came to that you think
there's a man because a lot of drug and
drug induced homosexuality in my area
yeah that's what i thought i was because
i did so many drugs i was like you just
you're not gay you just like did like
eight molly pills and you let anybody
blow you that doesn't make you gay yeah
yeah
yeah because a lot of you see a lot of
gay men meet up behind the rest area in
our town and they would do drugs and
then
get involved in the sexual activity
behind the rest area and people would
actually shoot these potato guns at them
they had like uh
because it was a river there was a river
right there and these two guys across
the river would you know not if they
were not doesn't sound like the spot to
go
just to break them up yeah it was like a
warning shot yeah it was all warning
shots but um it was like yeah cause i
guess they were just alarmed if there
was like drug induced homosexuality
that's what i think people were alarmed
at i mean people um potty man but yeah
or maybe they're just trying to be
uninhibited maybe i was gonna say i'm
just trying to
you know get get away from their
inhibitions and just like oh straight
people when they get really hot yeah
that was a different time when that was
going on but now yeah i think like yeah
because drugs will just make you a
little more brave i think almost to do
anything sometimes yeah and especially
if you're really clowned out dude you
[ __ ] and you're trying to eat your
own ass my uncle
he's got a point my uncle used to tell
us go look in your ass bro and when we
we'd [ __ ] be gone for like 40 minutes
they're trying to look at our own ass
you know it's a weird thing i remember
the first time i shaved my ass and was
like trying to find my hole in the
mirror and i was like i was like wow i
feel slightly like less confident in
myself by looking at myself from this
angle oh yeah but eventually you get you
know because that's that's your ass you
better live with it you know
staring in the ass i think it does
weaken you
yeah see i see i think it i think it
does at first right but for me because
at first i felt the same thing no it's
in the same as when my
it is empowering it is own your ass own
your whole own your whole yeah there you
go baby yeah i believe in my whole i
love that man oh yeah whole man we're
going all the way all right
i could always trust it you know yeah
it's right behind me at all times all
the time
when there was only one set of footsteps
in the sand there was really
a hole as well yeah
yeah um
what else could i ask you guys about oh
did you guys used to do demos and stuff
like that when y'all were coming up like
when you guys were escaped you guys ever
go to demos at different shops i'm sure
you that you probably did tony did you
do him as we did with him oh you did
and what was some of that life like like
was it awesome at that time did you guys
were you guys already kind of like
popular in that space was it like uh
was it pretty yeah just what was that
like i guess done it in every version so
i've done them where
no one knew about skating cared about
skating and then they put a half pipe in
the parking lot and people were like
what the hell is that
yeah yeah um and then uh
done it where it was wild and thousands
of people and stadiums yeah stadium type
stuff and then um
then when things kind of went south
again especially in the early 90s
uh we were doing
demos in parking lots of skate shops or
sporting goods stores and they would
just
put stuff up
so here's a box and here's a jump ramp
go ahead yeah and then
you know 50 people are watching
and we're trying to get we're trying to
get like 300 bucks from the shop so that
we can i was doing the same hotel room
it's almost like open mics with comedy
kind of yeah yeah yeah but we're not as
humiliated so we we did have to survive
open mic is more humiliating as a guy
that's trying to do stand-up it is way
it's way harder
mentally like skateboarding even when
you're because i've sucked at
skateboarding and been in a demo in a
contest i know what it's like to be the
[ __ ] guy on the ramp
i don't i don't even know where i stand
in comedy i don't give a [ __ ] if
everyone came just to see me
i'm [ __ ] myself yeah i don't know
what it is man i can talk in front of
thousands of people but stand up i've
never been more nervous in my [ __ ]
life wow and i it's that's what me
that's why i'm attracted to it because
i'm trying to figure out what that is i
had the greatest i'm only done a little
bit but i did a set with ryan sickler
and it was 500 people in a proper place
and i'm like i've never done a proper
place
and i right before i went out i was like
note to self my knee is shaking i'm like
why is your knee shaking
are you cold like i was like i think i
am i might be getting hypothermia i'm
like everyone else has got a t-shirt on
what is your deal
i'm like like after i was done i was
like yeah cool wow but what the [ __ ] was
that
i've had fights i fought chain card and
i was like man this is a bad idea i feel
real nervous
that was way more nerve-wracking this
holiday season the best deal in wireless
can only be found at mint mobile
mint mobile they
you know they don't have the brook and
mortar uh building
so you know there's no store that's how
they save the money
they say if we don't have to pay rent in
all these locations we can pass the
savings on to our users
right now when you switch to mint mobile
and buy a three month plan you get three
months for free
mint mobile lets you order from home and
save a ton with phone plans starting at
just 15 a month
all mint mobile plans come with
unlimited talk and text
and high speed data
delivered on the nation's largest 5g
network and that's fast speed
with mint mobile you choose the amount
of monthly data that's right for you
and stop paying for data that you never
use you don't have to do that
use your own phone with any mint mobile
plan that is beautiful you don't have to
get some new phone some new deal
that's not part of it
keep your same phone number keep all
your existing contacts switch to mint
mobile and get premium wireless service
starting at just
dollars a month for a limited time buy
any three month mint mobile plan and get
three months free
by going to mintmobile.com
t-h-e-o that's mint m-i-n-t
mobile.com
t-h-e-o
cut the wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month at mintmobile.com
theo
oh it's that time of new year to get
your body right
god don't you want that good body for 20
22.
don't you want to keep things fresh when
it comes to fitness
[Music]
and keep those thighs looking thai yay
well the peloton bike and bike plus are
ringing in the new year with so much new
that's right peloton new classes new
music new ways to keep your workouts fun
and motivating
peloton is stepping into the ring with
its newest discipline no gloves needed
they've got boxing yep
you might fight uh jake paul next
discover a fast furious and fun workout
with peloton instructors in your corner
they've got boxing they've got new
artist series music selections
you know a good a good fit descent or a
good uh
de baby or a good uh
reba
can help you stay fit and have the tunes
from pop and rock
to hip hop and edm
there are over 100 artists series to
choose from find your favorite music and
turn your next workout into a concert
there's more daily workout variety as
well it's easier to stick to your goals
when you keep your workouts interesting
peloton has a workout for every goal day
and even your mood
your mood's a little slow
they got something that'll meet you
right where you are stay motivated while
having fun bike workouts yoga meditation
dance cardio and more
for a limited time only try the peloton
app for free for two months then 12.99 a
month
after that
new members only visit one peloton dot
com slash app to learn more that's two
months free at o n e
p e l o t o n
dot com
offer expires 131 222 terms apply
is there a different kind of nerves then
okay let's let can we think about that
for a second because yeah what are those
different nerves was one nerve is
different than the other like the nerves
of going
like does it feel different i'm just
trying to think while i'm talking it's
nerves of pain because if you don't do
the trick right you're going to get
really hurt so that's a that's a that's
a nerve that's a nerve i have a lot of
skateboarding right but if we go do
demos there are things that we know
we're capable of that are tried and true
that are like sort of playing the hits
so we're going to go there and more
exciting no matter what i'm going to
leave here and people are going to think
i'm good at skateboarding right pretty
good skateboarding but when he's doing
something new like comedy
he doesn't know there's no standard set
for him but was there is there something
that you get nervous at that make that
like um
i'm just trying to equate like if i'm on
a skateboard ramp i can feel that right
now i get real scared of heights being
higher than i should be you know for
myself and so
um
that fear gets i feel like it's in my
stomach more and in my body yeah that's
definitely my body whereas if i'm going
out to do comedy or doing something like
karaoke makes me so nervous right that's
i'm trying to think of where that fear
is it's not really i guess it's more
like i can't sing right yeah and it's
more in my ego i feel like my a lot of
my fear from there comes but what about
when you started comedy were you really
nervous when you started
yeah i think i was pretty yeah i was i
was definitely nervous okay so there was
a was there a period of time where every
time before you went up you're like [ __ ]
i hope this works out yeah okay good
yeah but there there are still times
when i go in front of a crowd and it's a
new ramp or whatever and
i am so nervous because i don't have the
confidence that maybe it's my ramp or
because the crowd's way bigger and
louder than i imagined and all of a
sudden my body won't work the way that
oh yeah that it should and and i'm
bailing stuff that i can do in my sleep
and that's when i i have to reassess and
and try to do even exercises where it's
like come on just just snap into being
normal see his demo is different than
because i've done demos with him yeah
and there's
20 of us sometimes all like the best
dudes in the world but it's like 5 000
people
four and a half thousand people are
looking at everything he does oh yeah
and you can tell you know like he'll
drop in and it's like
you feel every so i feel like the
pressure because i'm there and it's like
oh i got tony hawk's friends all right
here i mean or he [ __ ] sucks either
way you didn't care who am i
but i guess sometimes that gets the best
of me right um usually i can i can
overcome it but sometimes it does and it
doesn't last long i've never never done
a demo where i felt like i
couldn't figure it out the whole time
did you uh
did did at any point like like did your
was there a part in your career where
your ego started to get big like you
felt that going on in your world like
i've noticed that in my own life at
times your ego because it's kind of like
this plant that gets watered by not even
you water in it you know it's this thing
that grows sometimes did you ever have
any uh i would say
more in the in the like mid to late 80s
when all of a sudden we were thrust into
stardom
and in a thing that we never imagined
we'd be famous at because no one was
famous at it and then all of a sudden
we're traveling the world and there's
crowds and then that that definitely
gets to you at when you're in such an
impressionable impressionable formative
age so when i'm like 18 19 traveling the
world thousands of people autographs
you know parties girls everything and it
was just like at some point i think that
i took it for granted yeah and maybe
even expected it
and then it was all taken away from me
because skating died and now
now that i get to live through another
wave of success i don't take any for
granted and i'm right just so thankful
that they even get paid to do it at all
um i'm glad i went through that
yeah dude when like
like with the ego do you think it like
um it's do you think it's just something
that happens to people because that's an
interesting experience that you've had
where you got to like you know you just
got to have
you know popularity and stuff like that
i feel like the people who have the
worst egos are the ones that
get into it for those motivations oh
they get into it for fame or fortune
and then when they finally get it they
just expect it
and
maybe that'll last for a little bit but
at some point people are over you yeah
if you're walking around like you
deserve all of it they had a plan it was
a secret plan to be an [ __ ] the whole
time oh
yeah that's what it looks like yeah
because some people are just like i knew
you
before you were that right and now
we're still on the same [ __ ] planet
dude with the same skin on and you're
acting like all of a sudden you're made
of [ __ ] diamonds but you do see those
same those same people
lose their motivation and they don't
keep their skills up because it was
never there probably to begin with or it
was it was there but but they the
motivation was just to get to this point
of celebrity and when they get to that
point they don't they're not motivated
to get better
and that's when they fall off
and so in my case i just want to keep
getting better at skating
thank god that was there for you then
just because it's like that kind of
stuff can happen you know it's like
sometimes i think it happens and people
don't realize it till years later you
know like what was even going on if you
realize that at the time you'd probably
stop
like what do you mean like if you're
being an egotistical [ __ ] right
you're not appreciating where you are
and you realize that right there and
then then you would prob hopefully he
would stop or
make a like get on the right track or
try to get on the right track i've done
it i did it with the radio skateboarding
i was famous not as famous as him but
famous enough to be an [ __ ] and fly
around the world and be like ah
it was nothing i wasn't like on purpose
mean but i was definitely
like not appreciative of
the people and all the the life that i
was living just like no thank you just
[ __ ] give me the [ __ ] give me the
money give me that juice
[Laughter]
and then the radio same thing yeah got i
didn't it was accidental got real big
all of a sudden people were all up my
ass and then i'm straight back into that
thing running everybody i know what i'm
doing [ __ ] nobody knows anything
and then had to you know go that's when
i started going to therapy and [ __ ]
because i couldn't have a relationship
yeah like i could be the boss of a show
but nobody would date me oh dude that's
where i'm at
really yeah nobody will date you because
you would you snap on people or
something no people can date me i just
have trouble like with commitment and
stuff like that like i've just been and
i've just been i've just had so much
anger and i don't know what i'm angry at
that that is i know exactly what that is
being super angry and not knowing why
that was the thing that made me go
because i was
i had everything i was like i have
everything that i'd ever want like
you're on fire and all you do is [ __ ]
talk about dicks and then you go home
and do whatever you want like this is
no and what was your other job i was a
skateboarder yeah like come on
you can't get a better life and you're
just no or you mean i really just want
to listen to some dark metal by myself
and think about pulling things apart
like what's wrong with you dude
i'll go get those chickens at the store
and just take them apart man
wait are they cooked huh
oh yeah they're cooked they're
pre-cooked
what do you mean you buy a chicken to
pull it apart i'll put on elliott smith
or some sad music and just [ __ ] carve
that [ __ ] up so do you eat it as well
or you're just carving i'll have a
little sometimes but sometimes it's more
for the sport of it honestly you know
it's like yeah somehow i just gotta let
it's just like i just want yeah i don't
know i just get out i've just been angry
and man it's been it has been not fun
you know she's doing
that is a unique um outlet
i've never heard of someone pulling
apart chickens it's not a good i feel
like you could do better as
an escape yeah it's an inner i think
when you're in a city and you don't you
don't have you know you it's like more
of a
you know it's if you're in outside you
know you're out you there's a place
where you could go do something and get
a good
you know do a weapon or something like
that i would do that huh didn't you do
yeah i'll do it sometimes it's been hard
when i'm in la it's tough and when i'm
touring it's tough
so it's hard to like really lock into
stuff that's one hard thing it's about
touring
um what are you doing tour
you could bring a jiu jitsu guy and mats
and roll every day in your room but that
is ridiculous yeah as i'm saying it
shut up
that's some rich guy [ __ ] as yeah dude
he can act like a but he's [ __ ] floyd
get the [ __ ] out of here [ __ ] rich
get the [ __ ] i will never be based on
the reaction of my
kids yeah you got something i don't know
what it is dude you're holding something
your kids have obviously been misled by
a prominent male in their life
okay
because no
no every you're fearful oh never [ __ ]
my oldest son riley um is not here my
step kids are here myles and calvin um
but my oldest son riley said you didn't
theovonne and then sent me a photo of
the shirt he's wearing which is your
shirt today that happened
that's pretty
are you off that shirt yeah it's a good
shirt man
your podcasts are huge that's my
brother's favorite shirt yeah man i mean
i do fine i just will never feel rich i
don't know was it more like you just
never say it because it sounds wrong
yeah i just would never want to be rich
dude that [ __ ] sounds [ __ ] i feel
like
being some rich guy i'm going to get a
briefcase i'm going to [ __ ] why do
you have to get a briefcase
you got to do i'm not doing all of that
[ __ ] dude you just have to work in
administration huh yeah but i'm just not
like
you know
i'm not doing that bro so you give your
money to charity or something i could we
give away a decent amount you know but
but yeah i mean i guess maybe i'll have
some money but i'll hopefully never be
rich like in my head you know i think i
always just looked like i despised rich
people i think so i think i have some
issues with it probably you know
but um
what else dude so what about um a good
product you guys ever have a good
product here's a question right here
from some white
i thought there was going to be
something on the end of that just
this guy knows bro look at him
another guy i'm a big fan of both of you
but i have a question for tony back in
you landed the 900 on the half pipe
i don't know if it's the only one that's
been landed but
regardless of all that the post
interview you said uh
it was the best day of your life
uh my question is
is there a trick that surpassed the 900
after that or is that still the best day
of your life and uh theo a couple days
ago i've been rocking the mullet first
haircut
ever i've been getting my mom to cut my
hair oh yeah um for my whole life but
that's the first professional cut and i
chose a mullet so shout out to you gang
gang gang baby grow it out baby let god
hang on the back
um
uh yes but well
after i did 900 at the x games then a
few other people learned it um within
the same year and then uh
tom shar did a 1080
about 10 years later didn't hurt your
feelings when you did it
no
he's not that guy
yeah
and there was no way i was ever gonna
try that
what i went through with 900's and even
after i made it and some of the slams i
took
after i could do it
knowing that i'd have to try to spin
another rotation no
um and then let's see 1080 then mitchie
brusco did a 1080.
then mitchie briscoe went on to do a
1260. so that is
that is the record no one has done a
1260. [ __ ] one mega right mega three and
a half spins in the air on the mega ramp
too yeah you know what that is no it's
like a 30 foot quarter pipe twice as big
as a vote ramp yeah so you get more air
it's like 18 feet high enough man enough
is enough dude enough yeah but you
didn't say but but but also that that
thing sometimes comes back to bite me
was saying it was a good greatest day in
my life i was i was overcome with
emotion it's supposed to be when your
kids are born right did you get yeah
well also my
my uh my wife at the time and our
newborn was right there so that that
didn't that wasn't a good idea you got
to let him leave man the 900 was a
really bad thing but also there there
was i i tried to defend it which was not
a good idea too um
i meant to say it's the greatest day of
my career
skating career but also there was a part
of me that was like well you know what
i've been trying nine hundreds for about
ten years
i haven't been trying to have kids for
you know what i mean yeah that's a good
call man it was one of the greatest days
for skateboarding's life like that's how
big of a deal it was well i heard about
it and i didn't know anything about
skateboarding right yeah i could tell
believe in it i could tell when he did
it the people that didn't skate were
like this is a big deal usually
it's just us that k you know right yeah
i mean when i learned 720s it was in
1985 on a backyard ramp in stockholm
sweden there were two people there
no one cared
you know i was like oh that was cool new
spin
yeah but then that [ __ ] flew around the
world
and you know because there was no
internet but i heard you did that yeah
but you were you were you were also
in the community and it's a very small
community of skateboarding but that one
because it was on espn
and because they showed it live
um it just kind of went viral when also
yeah i mean the video game too when that
popped me it was like that video game
was almost like it was almost like a
tick tock video now like everybody can
make a video game in 30 seconds on their
phone you know it's like but back then
there was only a few videos that got it
was like
you know
so a video game was almost just like a
youtube video now in a way you know it
was like a way to see something
different you know there wasn't that
many mo there was television movie or
video game there wasn't anything else
it's like the hip-hop era the the the
gold what is it the gold era where it's
like if you're a hip-hop if you're a big
hip-hop artist in the late 80s 90s then
you're still
a hip-hop artist today it's very hard to
be from another generation and still be
solid right like he cr with the video
game it's a video game that's because
there's games that were invented 10
years ago that my kid plays now it's got
respect
but
there's not many of those it's always
like ever changing tony hawk's video
game seems like
my kid
doesn't he knows what's cool that's
usually the first thing people say to me
now who
grew up either you know knowing my name
or or recognizing me if someone
recognized me that happened today she's
like oh what tony i'm gonna
video games that happened in the parking
lot actually i uh just i went to a
restaurant before i got here and when i
got in my car this dude like jumped out
of his car stopped his car jumped out he
was like yo man
and then he saw my skateboard like this
he saw myself yeah he's like he's like
let me get a clip do a trick
and so i grabbed the skateboard and went
down the parking garage
i did because i was going to the
restaurant and i was going to skate
there anyway but i was just like yeah
catch me as i'm leaving
um what a guy do uh
um
was there any product you guys ever
pushed that was kind of crazy like was
there a product that got presented to
you guys that was like kind of bananas
like uh
that you guys ever did we sell out are
you saying like kid rock kid rock tells
a story about like he got involved with
this company called badass beer right
and so he like made like a meal like an
empire made his own beer right and i
think that's what it was it was zombie
right but the second batch of it was
[ __ ] horrible they just cooked it too
long or something but they still put it
out right which was that was not the
best move i don't think but so it just
cannibalized the whole thing everybody's
like this [ __ ] beer is is is is [ __ ]
you know so
um
i worked with a company that that i
didn't realize it was in the 80s that i
didn't realize i had signed away
my rights to them
and i had no idea what that meant i was
i was whatever 19 or something and and
uh they just started making products
with my name on it and i finally came to
them i was like you guys this sucks you
can't do this they're like actually we
can yeah you know it was more it was
more like like a cooking robe
it was a
it was a velcro wallet which was fine
with um basically they stole the vision
streetwear logo and it just said tony
hawk gear they ripped off two people
yeah and i just said you guys this is
vision streetwear yeah and they're like
yeah well the tri-bar logos are hot
right now like yeah but this is vision
streetwear and then you're putting my
name on it so it looks like i'm ripping
off vision streamwear and i'm a skate
i'm a skater their escape brand like and
i don't ride for them yeah and they were
just like no and while i was talking to
this dude this is a true story while i
was talking to this dude
behind him on his shelf is a roll of
toilet paper with the same logo he put
vision street wear on toilets tony hawk
gear
tony hawk toilet paper yeah and i was
like
what is that
and he goes he goes oh that oh that's
one of our one of our retailers said uh
said yeah man we'll take whatever you
got with tony hawk's name you can put
toilet paper on there and it'll sell so
we made that for him wow and i was like
that's dude i'm i want out of here and i
had i actually paid to get out of my
contract damn
them t-hawk [ __ ] tickets i'd take a box
of them bro
i keep a box of them on deck you should
keep that in your uh in your glove box
we had what was it and one time they had
this thing it was like it was like kind
of hard condoms or whatever i think and
it was like
it was condoms were already a little
harder than regular so it was like
hotter like the material yeah
yeah so you didn't have to get as hard
built in viagra oh
it's got like a
spine in it yeah it's got like a little
bit
it was like called chance condoms or
something i don't know can you pull it
up chance condoms no way
backbone makes more sense but it was
like yeah endorsing them it was like
we'll meet you halfway or something was
their thing i've got ten wait you were
sponsored by it we did it for yeah we
did it for like four like maybe four uh
ad reads or something it was like yeah
you never should put one on partially
hard condoms maybe holy sh no way i go
partially hard condoms man
[Laughter]
no you guys must have the most insane
search history and just go to images i
think let's see some pics here you got
to judge about it by the jpeg on this
um
a little aidsy at the top scoot down a
little
uh yellow one is that that kind of slips
off
wow i'm gonna have to get a hold of some
if we still have any at the
at the other place man but yeah we have
partial what else did we have
that was bizarre
um
did you did you deny anything
uh we denied some stuff like some sexual
stuff alcohol we don't do
uh
[Music]
i don't know if there's been anything
else i've seen a lot of merch people
come to my show i'm like oh and i'm like
i've never we've never made that yeah i
i denied a tour yeah there was a tour
that went on you probably heard about it
in malaysia where it was like an extreme
sports tour yeah and it was uh it was
skateboarding and bmx and i maybe
inlining cool um and it was at a time
when there was no it was before x games
were were big and the whole tour was
sponsored by benson and hedges yeah
sweet cigarettes grandpa cigarettes and
there were some skaters that went that
were
like sober skaters
smoking didn't smoke didn't drink and
went to and did the tour sponsors i was
like you guys okay
and they started smoking probably no
they didn't but i was i was shocked
because i i chose not to do it i was
like i don't want to go to a i don't
want to have a sponsored drop in a
tobacco sponsored skate tour and it was
going to be uh it was going to be 18 and
over too because it's sponsored by
tobacco so i was like so there's always
kids can't see us
and so it just didn't feel right to me
so i didn't and whatever i'm not trying
to say i'm holier than that just
rubbing it no look we did it
the irony about all of that was it was
right at the time when all those crazy
fires were happening in malaysia
and so the second half of the tour got
cancelled because of smoke
no i mean sorry but yeah i saw a thick
sister fight a monkey but for a bag of
chips in malaysia one time we were on a
field trip wait it was a thing that you
could watch she did it more than once no
monkeys are gnarly yeah we went and they
i got to go later on and they come and
steal your food yeah they're garlic and
the wood she was fighting back out there
yeah with a big bag of ruffles on her
and this these [ __ ] came
through son who shows up to that area
with a big bag of ruffles like you're
asking for oh i like this girl i went
with riley and riley and i were there's
this area where all these monkeys are
known to and there was this little snack
thing we got chips as soon as we got
them they're just like
and they take the whole bag look at this
beating up this white dude right here
monkeys love [ __ ] chips bro
what's that
no the thing he's holding is that some
kind of weird cucumber no they're crazy
they got everything dude they're wild
bro i got a photo of one of them
giving me like
a look like he's gonna bite me yeah
were you at the birth of your children
were you did you ever go in the room
during childbirth that's crazy
what that's crazy my dad said he went
and watched uh looked at cars when i was
getting born but he also said that uh
you know
your mum got pregnant and
you know i thought about
running but i stayed
so it wasn't it was a different
different time yeah now
you can't not be there for the baby
that's like uh unless you're divorced or
in the middle of divorce
you're getting big like i i can't even
queasy okay i just don't know i'm
wondering if it's the same type of
nerves if you get if you're dropping in
on a big ramp or something
it's pretty scary i think that's a
different experience but it is scary
it's scary i feel like if you had more
than one then it's less scary it's the
second one and if you have more than one
it happens real fast oh really yeah oh
the second one comes out quicker yeah oh
that first one's that real rocker huh
yeah
that first one's a real trap smasher dog
i destroyed my mum one time when she was
real angry she pulled her shirt up
because she had like stretch marks that
were real bad
and there and uh look what you did to me
and i remember i thought they were
stitches it looked like a shark attack i
was like oh i'm so sorry because
apparently i was i was 11 pounds and i
was a lazy baby so i was like i'm just
chilling and they're like trying to grab
on my big fat leg and i was like
like a beached whale just yeah just
beached up in a badge just chilling
dude i saw i was in new york one time
and somebody jumped off a building right
and took in their life and uh so i was
just kind of meandering around just kind
of seeing what was going on
and
this lady's like you know what and i was
like i was like what happened she was
like you wanted to know and i was like
yeah i want to know and then she pulled
up her dress right
and uh said that the guy jumped off the
building and landed in her
nice
so was his feet hanging at her no she
just said that and so i'm like this
lady's crazy right like but just what a
crazy thing to think right she was she
was bonkers seemed like she just wanted
to show you her [ __ ] yeah baby
but i fell for it
yeah who doesn't you know who doesn't
that would get me that would get me time
and time again i don't know how many
times ah you got me yeah yeah once again
the old caught a guy in my vagina
yeah every works every time man
uh we got one or two more questions man
and then we'll uh get y'all on your way
here's some guy from that's right hey
what's up theo so i had a question for
jason mr jason ellis
since you were a pro fighter what would
be
who's a pro fighter of yours either past
or present time
that you wish you shared the ring with
love you
brother gang gang praise the lord baby
ptl baby
i i don't think it's a good idea that
everybody i think who's really cool in
fighting that i would
share the every time i share the ring
with someone who i think is really cool
at fighting i usually get beat up pretty
bad really yeah it's kind of what i want
to do so because it's like the full
experience of what's it like to spar
with like keith jaradine and i don't
want keith jardine to not punch me that
would be like
not really sparring right so yeah i've
done that with a few of those people but
to fight fight with one of those people
i
i'm not i'm not insane i don't want to
die you know like i fight because it's
fun but i don't want to like have a
full death wish fight yeah and i feel
like that's what would happen if it was
all the people that i think is
is really i sparred dominick cruz once
before a fight wow and he like really he
like uh after it because he staggered me
like he caught me really good because
he's obviously a thousand times better
and that was just going to happen and he
caught me and and i got staggered and i
kept fighting and then afterwards
he said to me uh you know when i rocked
you there and you kept going
that's all you're gonna need for this
fight like i know you're ready for this
fight i know you can win this fight
because you showed me the thing that i
was the only question that i had is what
what happens when you get rocked and i
thought
you actually knew you were going to
concuss me
and to see how i was going to react
that's beautiful i appreciate the help
but it was also like you guys are insane
and i'm only yeah but he said pro
fighter i'm not a pro i've had a i've
had a couple pro fights but i'm not a
pro fighter i know what a pro fighter is
that's why i don't need to say like the
idea that he did hit you and you go down
like nah you don't have it yeah yeah no
but it's gonna work out for you yeah
yeah was he gonna tell me that when i
woke up or something or
yeah i don't know how that was just
testing you but those yeah yeah man not
for you guys
i guess i would that'd be a sign in
itself not for you guy
um we got one more question that came in
right here actually
what's up fellas this is tim from
windsor ontario canada
tony i know you put out a board that had
your blood in the paint i was wondering
if you're going to be putting out any
other products with your blood in it
and jason if you could put out a product
with your blood in it what product would
you put out thanks fellas
[Laughter]
that's an awesome question
uh
no but uh actually that that all
happened with liquid death and the
reason it happened was because they were
talking about doing some sort of unique
promotion
and they presented that idea to me
and i grew up a fan of kiss in the 70s
oh yeah yeah and kiss did that in comic
books in marvel comics they they made a
kiss comic book and all the members of
the band put their blood into the ink
vat wow and i thought that was one of
the coolest things ever and so there's
people are saying like at satanic and
whatever somehow i was copying little
nos x but i didn't even know about his
thing when i did it yeah um but that's
what that was the motivation and then
when we went to do it it caused a big
ruckus because well for one some people
thought it was weird gross evil awesome
and then other people thought that it
was a copy of lil nah's ex
and then but people have done it forever
well you're saying it's like yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah but i'm just saying that
was that was my motivation so to answer
this question no no more blood no more
when you go players you throw something
in there
i'm about to like shoot blood loads into
meat pies and tacos
i feel like signature jason ellis meat
pies with a little bit of blood coming
there oh yeah yeah for the for the
community it's gonna get edgy you know
like what am i gonna do like come in
what if there's a resource blood toys
like it's ridiculous i gotta come in
heavy yeah yeah
blood guitar or you know some like blood
like a bumper bar for trucks with good
recipe yeah or a toilet toilet seat with
blood oh it was it was hard to find um a
uh skateboard screening company that
would do it really yeah well some people
thought what it was this uh satan or
something yeah uh and then well i mean
other just people yeah but but the the
companies like the screening companies
they just were like i don't want to deal
with blood
right i feel like it's little bunch of
wimps right
what's a little blood we're all blood
man yeah yeah yeah but during the time i
get it like during the time it's just
like
yeah here's some plasma
whatever these days who knows
my wife's into that stuff is she really
yeah oh jeepers i get nervous
because you only have a certain amount
of blood in you that's what's
interesting
you know what's weird is how when you
lose some blood that you make more blood
inside i'm like where's that come from
yeah
i don't know how to make it
jesus christ makes the blood i mean who
else does
who else is going to stay up honestly
prometheus okay well whatever you want
to call him dude i know he has a [ __ ]
cup of screen saying you ain't got a
beard or [ __ ] more of a big
really giant jacked bold guy more i'm
not hey look his ig handle could be
prometheus for sure i'm not sure he's
not why that's why
he's mixed probably yeah um anything
else we got i know we got uh oh oh
that's my last question what kind of
guests are you guys going to have uh on
i want to come back on and uh and be a
guest sometime if you're not yes yeah i
do we'll we'll have you on anytime you
want yeah oh you want to try and escape
i don't know just on the bottom not drop
in oh yeah dude i'll skate straight
across the bottom is there like a like
uh
yeah
i can already tell the breeze
he wants a harness yeah i want to give
on a horse yeah
i just wait there's a horse are you
skating i just need some help brother
yeah we'll give you hell okay i'm not
bringing a [ __ ] harness for you you
can hold my heart my hand if you want oh
whoa hold on bro what it's not like that
doesn't say my dick my hand two
different things yeah but i'll wear a
glove if it makes it more hair dryer
yeah but you'll put the glove on your
dick i know you
i know it's a gateway you'd be like
that's a weird hand it's only got one
finger yeah dude damn why does this hand
have a hard semi-hard condom already on
um we have had guests we've had
a couple of skateboarders yeah skater
and jack jack black um oh i didn't know
that we had poopies who's the newest um
jackass member and he talked about his
shark attack which was fascinating and
frightening uh
uh
[ __ ]
tiger belly
yeah he said he would oh bobby bobby's
saying him down yeah huge um but and we
i don't know when this is airing but we
just did rodney mullen and that's going
to come out soon and that was pretty
amazing yeah he knows who he is but he's
kind of the godfather of modern
skateboarding oh that's grace he's the
guy he's the guy that invented k flips
wow
anthony sexy flips and heelflips and
he's still his stories
it's the most insane story of any human
life is it really
right now
still skateboarding at night in the dark
he only goes it's 55 and he goes at
midnight and skates till 5 in the
morning and then he goes home and goes
to sleep and then when he lived in
london because his girlfriend's there
working
i was like doesn't it rain there and he
goes yeah i bring a wet board and i'm
like what's a wet board it's like a
board that's like waterlogged and i just
skate in the rain and i'm like do you
bring like a rain jacket he's like no
just take my shirt off
so at mid at four in the morning you can
catch rodney mullen in london
doing skateboard tricks by himself for
hours damn still
that's cool
the skate community is very excited that
we got rodney on the show because rodney
does not do very many interviews at all
that's awesome man well congratulations
dude i'm really excited to see what you
guys do with it and it seems like it's
kind of meant to be that you guys had
started out and kind of done something
and then a lot of
relationships even work or not are hard
to you know especially in work or hard
to bring back together you know
sometimes it doesn't happen so yeah
to to run it back i think is pretty cool
kind of gives it a new power it's
awesome man i've never had more fun it's
not a job you know yeah it's like i get
to talk to myself calm down that's cool
yeah dude i'm going to come down we'll
ask you questions yeah i'd love to man
and bring the rest of your kids
uh make no mistake don't be there
oh yeah really yeah
these guys these guys are in college
i have uh another one that's in college
in colorado um another one that lives in
florida damn he's out of college i want
to be rich brother have all them kids
dog he's a busy dick right yeah boy
damn
well
uh no it was a pleasure to meet you and
it was a pleasure to meet you
i love everything you got a busy dick
all right good to see you guys look
these things never end well man
it's like
it's like a first marriage man these
things just are what they are you know
she's not a fan of the clothes i'm glad
they don't go away mad just go away yeah
yeah dude no stalkers this is our new
podcast no stalkers there you go uh and
thank you guys man and uh yeah i'd love
to come on man i'd like to come on in
february hopefully if you guys will have
me yep awesome thanks
now i'm cheers floating on the breeze
and i feel i'm falling like these leaves
i must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share
[Music]
a little time
for me to set that parking brake
and let myself on my heart
shine that light on me
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my story
just
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my old hands
and these rails that i've been riding on
there
[Music]